)
- Elle a 19 ans et attend
son deuxième enfant.rrrrrrrrrrrl
à se remettre de ses émotions,
deux jours après
son arrestation. D D D D D D D ?
- Si.
- C'est une des nouvelles
tactiques de la police
dominicaine : repérer
s s s femmes haïtiennes enceints
sans papiers, qui viennent
de la capitale. Naïka Pierre a e
par une ONG haïtienne
à Bellafrfrfrfrfrfrfrfrfrfrfrfre
un des points de passage
importants entre les deux pays.
RIGARD ORBÉ, Groupe d'Appui
au
- On a des migrants qui
témoignent avoir été victimes
de maltraitance et de brutalité
policière. Et certains migrantss
à l'intérieur dessososons.
- Ce haut fonctionnaire
dominicain, responsable
avec Haïti, se dit lui aussi
outré par la manière utilisée
lors de ces expulsions massives,
Luis Abinader. Mais Julio Ortega
partage les inquiétudes de
son gouvernement.
des relations avec Haïti
- 30 %... 30 de budget en santé,
des ministères de la Sa
et des services d'assurance
de santé, c'est dépensépour laï.
- Ce père de famille habi
à Martissant, quartier
par la guerrs s s gangs armés,
depuis juin 2021. Il attendait
n'arrivait pas. Incapable
de travailler, il s'est enfui
avec sa femme et son fils.
pour vous et votre famille
à cause de la violence?
Pourquoi? Parce qu'il y endede?
sans avoir le temps d'aviser
sa femme.
ici. Elle est complètement
démunie. Elle vivait depuis
6 ans en République dominicaine
ses enfants, tous sans papiers,
comme la grande majorité des
Haïtiens exilés dans ce pays.
Naïka, enceinte de 7 mois,
été transportées dans un camion
comme celui-ci...
où les gens sont entassés,ururu,
pendant des heur
Le poste-frontière de
Belladère est fréquenté
par des commerçants en tous...ïs
qui cherchent à fuir la crise
Mais ces jours-ci, la plupart
sont forcés de faire le trinini.
- On rapatrie les perssss
à 8 h 15 dans la soirée.
Et hier soir, on éta
la frontière pour recevoir
plus de 200 penenenes.
- Selon des médias dominicains,
illégaux sont expulsés
chaque jour depuis le décret
- Les États-Unis,
ils expulsent plus que nous.
Ce qui se passe ici, je vousdis.
Mais on ne veut pas recevoir
des leçons de comportement,
surtout des États-Unis.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ces adolescents ont aussi
dominicaines. Certains d'entre
eux ont été séparés de leurs
par une ONG spécialisée,
partenaire de l'UNICEF.
RICHARD FORTUNÉ,i i i i i i i in
- C'est un acte raciste même.
Ils sont arrivés ici... ont
passés plus de deux semainessos,
à la nourriture, tout ça.
La communauté internationalente
chose.
- La Commission des droitseseses
exige que ces déportations
massives cessent, le temps
qu'on trouve une solutionisisiï.
- La communauté internationale
doit prendre cette situation
en charge et faire un planMaMaM.
- Qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire?totototototototototototot.
- Naïka, la jeune maman,
se demande de quel côté
de la frontière elle pourranenes
semaines. Peut-être avecsasasaïu
avec son mari à Saint-Domingue,
où elle souhaite retourner.
♪ ♪